router
um what do you think what root word is
underneath the word rather
it's it's there you just have to take
one letter off
yes root i don't know it's a bit weird
americans say route
but i suppose we would be a bit weird if
we pronounced it
well anyway it's a router okay now what
does a router do
this idea of a hub or a switch is very
simple so far
right it's just a very very tiny network
of very few nodes okay
so if your network just looked like this
then you could get away with
just having a hub or a switch however
if you have a more complicated network
oops
uh no these are pretty lousy actually
uh yeah
um if you have a network like this so
what is this by the way what topology is
that do you remember
it's it's it's a kind of mesh there are
two kinds of mesh do you remember which
one it is
what are the two kinds of mesh do you
remember
the two kinds of mesh have to do with
how many connections you've got
a full mesh means every node is
connected to every single other node
what was the other one
not full it's partial okay so anyway
lots of nodes are connected to lots of
nodes but not every single one anyway
have a look at this
okay let's uh let me do this actually
haha take that into there okay so um
suppose am i still probably no i'm not
you are
this node over here okay and you want to
communicate with this node over here
now how are you going to get there you
could use a hub if you like
that would certainly get it across to
everyone eventually you get there
you could use a switch but suppose your
switch was here
and you're like hey dude can you please
get a message over there for me
where would the switch go where would it
send its message to
where would you guess
it's kind of tricky isn't it um because
there's lots of different ways
there's literally hundreds of different
parts i can go okay
and you might think we'll take the
shortest one uh you know the shortest
one looks a bit like
here to here to here
to here
here here i don't know what's that one
two three
four five six steps that's pretty good
right
but you don't know you know for example
these connections between them
some are fast and some are slow right
it's a bit like you're driving along
and some roads some back streets are
quicker than the main street even though
the main street's bigger but it's got
more traffic and so on right
it's a complicated question of what is
the quickest
route to get to your destination okay
this is actually a very very complex
problem
so therefore uh we have a whole piece of
technology devoted
to trying to work out what's the fastest
route
okay so switch in a simple network
it can nudge you in the right direction
okay but it can't tell you what's the
fastest way
or what's the most efficient way or
what's the way that's most likely to
actually get your data to its
destination and not have a lost
okay a router knows more about the kind
of network it's in
okay so router will be aware of
what the shortest path is how long each
path is meant to take
how error prone each type path is and so
the router knows a lot
okay and so it can make a more
sophisticated decision does that make
sense
okay